permission I want to give him permission  but I I think if you get a high value  man if you if you choose to marry if I  chose to go down the path of high value  man then that would also be signing up  for high value problems so if I chose to  go down that path I would know that it's  a possibility and I don't think I would  want to ruin an entire family over that  so what would I give him permission no  but if it happened am I gonna break up  my whole home probably not but I will  say My Views have changed on that  because that's a very hard pill to  swallow but the one thing you have to  know as a girl it's like if you choose  that guy then just know that might come  with it